hey guys and welcome to Berlin I'm here
with a language ear or heads gobble
gobble
hi I'm Gabrielle I'm the owner of the
website profit da de which teaches about
language for German speakers so I met
Gabrielle actually we met on the
Internet
two years ago we gave him an interview
and then we metals in Bratislava
and we became friends and here we are
and we thought we brainstormed about a
way we can help you language learners in
some in some aspects of language
learning and we thought that vocabulary
acquisition is a great idea so we're
going to talk about the five most common
and biggest mistakes that people
normally make when it comes to learning
vocabulary if you're wondering why you
can't commit these den words to your
long-term memory you are making one or
all of the mistakes we're going to talk
about so without further ado let's get
started I will talk about one mistake he
will talk about another mistake and here
we go the first biggest mistake that
people make is normally to try to
memorize words words are part of a
system part of a network and you always
have to make sure that you learn them in
context and you make them part of a
bigger system if you try to rote
memorized words it's not gonna it's not
gonna happen you know and like making
lists and try to cram words one by one
and you have to find other strategies in
order to commit words to your long-term
memory and once again make them part of
a network because that is the real key
to acquiring vocabulary in a language
the second biggest mistake is to learn
words that you don't need you should
only learn words that you can actually
apply that you actually use that you
need if you learn words that you don't
need and that's really common in school
and in textbooks where there's sometimes
situations dialogues whatever that
nobody ever encounters like that in real
life then you learn words that you don't
need and there's a few problems with
that the first one is it's harder to
memorize a word that you don't actually
care about that you don't actually need
and
another problem with it is that once you
learn it what's gonna happen with it
you're never going to use it because you
don't need it and then you'll forget it
just as quickly so learning words that
you don't really need and can't apply is
the biggest mistake number two looka
very well said
mistake number three is to learn words
out of context it's really important
once again which relates to when the
mistake number one is to make sure that
you always learn words and context be it
forget about list or if you want to make
let's just create lists out of texts
that you read or text that you know
conversations that you hear it always
have to be something in context you
learn words in sentences sentences or
parts of a lot longer text so make sure
that you learn words always out of some
situation out of a text out of a
conversation because that is really key
and that is also how actually kids learn
to speak languages at a native-like
level the fourth biggest mistake and we
already touched upon that in the last
tip and the last mistake and an mistake
number two is to not apply words so if
you learn words maybe even out of
context or in context you actually need
to apply them which means you need to
either write them in the text in a sense
in a sentence or you need to speak and
use it in a sentence and only if you do
that you can actually memorize them if
you don't do that you learn them and you
might be good at it if people ask you
what the word means or you might
remember it in a vocabulary test but
when you actually need to use them you
won't remember you won't remember them
because you never applied them in a
real-life context okay great fantastic
last last big biggest mistake is the
Latins used to say very BA Volant said
scriptum anand which means that said
words or spoken words fly away like
birds well written words stay and that
is the reason why you should always make
sure that you JA
down words that is really easily done
because with the current technology we
can always you know jump downwards on
your notebook on your on your computer
on your phone but use paper and and
technology so that you can always always
make sure that you write words down when
you hear a conversation when you're
watching a movie when you're reading
text and make sure that you do that
because by doing that you're indirectly
and directly telling your brain this
these pieces of information that I'm
learning are really important most
people are kind of okay well I learn I
hear words I see words and I will learn
them it doesn't work that way you have
to put a little bit more of attention
and effort into it so to wrap it a lot
these are the five mistakes that people
normally make and there are other
mistakes but these are the biggest
mistakes and if you start changing and
there are strategies to overcome these
it's not the end of the world these are
just common mistakes that people make
and if you want to know more you can
click in the description box where you
will find a wealth of information of how
to learn or it's more effectively more
in practice more naturally and you're
going to have a lot of fun in the
process so thanks Gabrielle for for this
and we're going to make more videos here
and so stay tuned and we're going to see
you in the next episodes bye bye Clark
from Berlin ciao